mich hat heute eine Meldung der
Sportschau beschäftigt die für Furore
gesorgt hat die Nachricht bezahlte
Fanreisen zur Katar WM das klingt ja
erstmal wie in einem Märchen eine gute
Fee erscheint und verteilt mit ihrem
glitzernden Zauberstab ein
leidenschaftlicher Fans Flüge
Unterbringung und sogar taschengelder
zur WM klingt doch großartig doch in
diesem Fall ist die gute Fee eher der
böse Wolf denn die kostenlosen Fanreisen
beinhalten ein Verhaltenskodex also die
Reise der Fans wird bezahlt damit sie
dort und in den sozialen Netzwerken für
gute Stimmung sorgen und 450 Fans aus 59
Ländern seinen beteiligt die Teilnehmer
des fanlieder-netzwerks müssen unter dem
Slogan Katar the fans World Cup und dem
Hashtag i am Fan fröhlich posten die
Teilnehmenden Fans die wissen auch also
deren Reisezeit wird dass ihre Social
Media Beiträge beobachtet werden man
behält sich auch das Recht vor
Änderungen oder das Löschen von das zu
verlangen ja da muss ich direkt Herrn
Ralf Fragen ist es denn schon so bitter
steht es so bitter um die WM der sieht
schon Fans zum Klatschen eingeflogen
werden müssen auch es steht in vielen
Dingen bitter genug aber das ist so eine
die nächste Pointe in in dem ganzen
reichen gestern gab es habe ich gelesen
Spionage die in der FIFA hinter jedem
heerspioniert gut also oder eben nicht
gut aber sind das wirklich Fans wie
wurden die ausgewählt oder sind das
influencer die von denen sie genau
wussten dass sie eine Reichweite haben
es sind es sind Fans also es ist jetzt
nicht wie wenn jetzt beispielsweise
irgendeine Automarke sich Influenza
einfliegen lässt da wird wahrscheinlich
auch auf Reichweiten geguckt werden
das stimmt spannend fand ich aber auch
es werden direkt Menschen ausgeschlossen
mit einer bestimmten politischen
Gesinnung also es wird direkt auch
danach geschaut welchen politische
Gesinnung hat wie man eingestellt ist
und man darf nur fröhlich berichten und
zum Beispiel ich glaube wenn influencer
von Automarken beispielsweise genommen
werden sollten Sie ja auch einigermaßen
freiberichten dürfen hoffe ich mal und
dann sagen das alles
nicht um beruflich
da habe ich meine Zweifel ob es wirklich
verdient er nach irgendwelchen sind die
ausgewählt worden und nach die das
wirklich mit dem mit der mit der
Gießkanne gemacht also die katari sind
nicht doof das sollten wir mal zur
Kenntnis nehmen das sind Methoden von
denen du sagst einmal aber das ist doch
nicht unser Standard das ist ja Wahnsinn
so ja aber sie werden es so tun und wir
werden ja heute ein bisschen drüber
reden ich habe ein Problem heute zu
sagen es ist alles schlimm bei der
Vergabe 2010 da hätte man all diese
Kriterien anlegen müssen und der hätte
gerade niemals niemals diese WM bekommen
können heute müssen wir gucken wie wir
mit den Dingen die da zu rangekommen und
darauf hoffen dass ich ein bisschen was
tut aber wenn wir bei diesem Fan
Beispiel bleiben gab es das denn auch
bei anderen WMS dass Fans eingeladen
wurden unter Hashtags und gute Stimmung
zu machen oder ist es jetzt schon was
ganz Neues und auch erschreckend
eine andere WM ist als als alle anderen
ich kann mich nicht erinnern dass selbst
Russland 2018 da war die Krim schon
annektiert hatte ich nicht den Eindruck
dass die ganze Welt auf jault sondern da
war das hat man so ein bisschen
Stillschweigen zur Kenntnis genommen
Russland wurden die Fans nicht zum
Klatschen eingezogen aber hier ist es
offenbar nötig denn natürlich ist diese
WM so so toxisch und so belastet mit mit
1000 Dingen und zwar wirklich wichtigen
Dingen dass dass das kein normaler
Fußball sein wird und das ist die Kritik
gibt ist das Normalste von der Welt und
das dann aber der Betroffene wenn er
glaubt und wenn das seine Denkweise ist
das mit Geld lässt sich alles regeln und
das ist so in Katar in Katar dass sie
sich dann solche Methoden bedienen das
ist nicht unser Standard deswegen ich
die bämme den nie dort stattfinden
sollen nur jetzt dass ich das
stattfindet
bringt sehe ich ihn wenn man darüber
reden sehe ich in Boykott keinen Sinn
Heli würden sie sich bezahlen lassen um
zur WM zu fliegen also würden sie es
Angebot annehmen kostenlose
Unterbringung kostenlose Flüge
kostenloses Ticket dafür net Posten na
klar ich bin Fußballfan da
selbstverständlich wie ich das gucken
und ich finde es auch abenteuerlich und
auch ein bisschen lächerlich und
scheinheilig was wir jetzt für eine
Debatte führen also so kurz vor der WM
als hätte man wie Herr Ralf völlig
richtig sagt gleich nach der Vergabe es
jeden Menschen
mit Abstand schlechteste Bewerbung mit
Abstand weil jeder und sagt auch
sonst wäre England zu zugekommen richtig
England Australien war in der verloren
waren einige in der Verlosung jedenfalls
welche wir reden hier davon
Nachhaltigkeit da werden Start das weiß
ja jeder Stadien gebaut in der Wüste
klimatisiert Menschenrechte ich glaube
der Guardian hat getitel sechseinhalb
tausend Menschen in umgekommen bei dem
Bau ist doch ist doch ja und Katar
weigert sich auch die Fonds zu machen
oder aufzustehen um die jetzt zu
entschädigen die Frage wie man
Menschenleben entschädigen möchte dass
er jetzt er bei der hingestellt aber wie
also diese klatschenden Fans da würden
sie mitmachen ich würde mir das Spiel
angucken ich freue mich wenn sich nicht
einfliegen lassen auf Kosten von Katar
doch na klar ich bin natürlich würde ich
das machen weil was bringt es denn die
WM findet trotzdem statt auch wenn wir
jetzt sagen ich gucke das nicht ich habe
gestern eine Umfrage gesehen wer zu
Hause boykottiert am Fernseher
interessiert das die scheiß ich glaube
doch nicht wirklich deswegen gleich zum
Propaganda bitte machen
um als clarkeur dazu irgendwie ein # das
war nicht die Frage ob ich hinfahren
würde auf Kosten von den cataris ja eben
aber nicht diese Aktionen starten das
will natürlich machen ich lasse mir
nicht prostituieren das ist ja klar
Unternehmen aber nichts posten natürlich
okay
aber also sie würden es schon mal nicht
machen habe ich jetzt das Gefühl dass
die katharis jetzt einfliegen lassen
dürfen und sie machen dann vielleicht
sogar noch mit human white Swatch haben
sie Instagram Account wäre super für die
Karte ist ja es wäre den theoretisch
zuzutrauen denn es sind PR-Profis und
damit hätten wir vielleicht uns auf
ihrer Seite aber ich glaube im realen
Leben würden die mich nicht einladen die
mögen mich nicht gleich zu lange es ist
eben nicht erst jetzt dass die Kritik da
ist sondern wir haben schon vor der
Vergabe der WM auf die Misere auf die
Missstände auf den Baustellen in Katar
aufmerksam gemacht als dann außerdem
dieses
unterdrückerland dieses autoritär
geführte Land die
Weltmeisterschaft geschenkt bekommen hat
oder das war nicht ganz billig okay aber
das sieht dass sie eben das durfte
bekommen hat das hätten da gebe ich
Straße reif absolut Recht hätte nie
passieren dürfen so jetzt ist Katar wie
das eben war schon angedeutet wurde das
sind
PR-Spezialisten es gab einige
Verbesserungen weil das nicht gewundert
mit den Fans jetzt diese die Sache hat
mich zum Beispiel heute sehr verwundert
doch aber es ist schon ziemlich forscht
sowas aber nicht lang oder irgendwann
sagt man sich passt ja mal eben so ach
quatsch wirklich ja kein Wunder
sozusagen wie stark das Regime unter
Druck steht naja die Kritik ist ja
offensichtlich auch gehört worden
zumindest war so laut dass man sie nicht
ignorieren kann insofern
das Problem ist dass die Kritik dann
gehört wurde und auch was passiert ist
ungefähr vor fünf sechs sieben Jahren da
stand auch Qatar außenpolitisch unter
Druck weil die anderen Golfstaaten
angeführt von Saudi-Arabien Katar die
haben die Grenzen geschlossen zu Katar
die haben also gab es Feindseligkeiten
und plötzlich zeigten sich reformwillig
und haben sich so im WE dazu geneigt und
die Kritik ernst genommen wir waren da
wir haben mit den höchsten Politikern
dort gesprochen die haben große Reform
versprochen und dann gab es sie auch
allerdings zu wenig zu spät einige
wenige kommen jetzt in den Genuss dieser
Reform aber die vielen 100.000 Millionen
von Wanderarbeitern die vorher gelitten
haben die vielleicht gestorben sind
deren Hinterbliebene jetzt in bitterster
Armut sind so dass die Kinder nicht in
die Schule gehen können dass da also
wieder eine neue Generation von ja wann
das Sklaven sozusagen heranwächst das
ist Schuld der katharis die sich einfach
nicht dazu durchringen können und nicht
wollen wegen des Geldes weil es schön
billig ist können wir auch das Ändern
okay bleiben wir einmal noch bei der PR
Maschinerie und bei den Fans frau Klein
würden sie hinfliegen und zwar nicht
bezahlt von den cataris sondern selber
als Politikerin selbst bezahlt
also ich fand die Entscheidung immer
schon schwierig dass die WM an Katar
ging sie ist jetzt nun mal so wie sie
ist ich bin jetzt kein Vollblut
Fußballfan deswegen würde ich sowieso
nicht hinfahren aber wichtig ist ja
jetzt in der ganzen Debatte dass wir
nicht unfair gegenüber den Spielern sind
na also die bereiten sich vor die haben
hart trainiert die freuen sich auch auf
die WM und auf die Fußballfans freuen
sich auf die WM also grundsätzlich dass
wir da eine gute Stimmung haben dass wir
unsere Nationalmannschaft anfeuern und
Spaß am Spiel haben am Sport haben das
finde ich gut und wichtig selber würde
ich da auf jeden Fall nicht hinfahren
und kritisiere auch die
Menschenrechtsverletzungen die da
passiert sind und die Frauenrechte sind
auch ein Punkt ganz wichtiges Thema dass
sie ansprechen das kommt teilweise in
der Diskussion ein bisschen zu kurz wir
sprechen auch aus gutem Grund sehr viel
über die Arbeiter und das ist auch
richtig so auch
lgbtq-rechte sexuelle Minderheiten aber
auch Frau sexuelle absolut das nimmt mir
noch so ein bisschen wenig Raum ein in
der Debatte
grundsätzlich was da passiert und da
müssen wir eben auch drauf schauen dass
die Fans geschützt werden gerade
Homosexuelle Fans und auch Sportler